hello and welcome back to gamespot's
coverage of e3 2016. hello to all of the
folks watching on gamespot.com on twitch
and on youtube and especially to those
in europe going through the awful tiny
hour gauntlet uh we are we're here uh
hoping to show off what will maybe be
the best press conference of 2015 and i
say that folks because 2016 bethesda
definitely stole the show i'm delighted
to be joined by mr michael mccarty hey
fresh back from ea play yeah did you
have a good time there yeah played
battlefield played titanfall 2. which
one's better battlefield all right there
you
go
there you go get your pre-orders in
there folks an x-ray career what have
you been up to today uh
just doing nothing because i couldn't
remember ea so i just hung out just hung
out here yeah great job tomorrow hussein
have you been doing nothing as well no
i've been covering the hot news leaks
all the leaks springing leaks everywhere
you and the news team have been
perhaps more busy today than you
expected in the last year probably
and yeah and then i just got back from
playing uh wildlands which i'm not
allowed to talk about for a little while
longer can you talk about who you met at
wildlands
no okay actually not you're not gonna
talk about that yeah i'm not great talk
about that
it's a shame it's a shame it is a big
shame yeah but sorry but you can always
cheer yourself up by going back to your
hotel and watching judge dread just
because yeah yeah it'll be all right
it'll be cool anyway okay we got about
25 minutes until
bethesda kicks off so uh let's get
through those rumors first of all skyrim
remastered i feel like this is the third
year in a row we've been talking about
some sort of remaster reissue version of
skyrim for new consoles will it happen
this year michael maherty sure
great
for that reason michael there's one more
answer
it's like filling a gap between fallout
4 and kind of like whatever else is
coming next for the purported elder
scrolls six or whatever like abyss or
whatever it's gonna be called i have no
idea you've said that many many times
why do you think it's gonna be called
abyss well the naming convention the
elder scrolls you know you start off
with arena arena daggerfall daggerfall
is the name of the actual place where it
takes place it's true so then more sorry
it was it's daggerfall and then arena
and then more no it's not it's actually
raining and daggerfall so your your idea
does not hold on no no so more wins the
place and then oblivion takes place in
uh cyrodiil that's true skyrim is the
place so ostensibly six will not be
called where it's set so why would it be
called that random word you just picked
i don't know this just sounds cool is it
going like granular into like places
within oh yeah universal almost all the
time like elder scrolls ae uh a wooden
shack yeah
they're gonna run out of them eventually
i mean even the the shimmering isles is
actually a different section of uh
of the world which is not actually
connected to any of those yeah um but
yeah we'll have to see i mean
you're right like todd howard's team
takes its time on games fallout 4 came
out last year
you know presumably they started working
on the next one whenever it is but
do you think maybe alexa that they kind
of really appreciated that whole we're
going to announce a game and it's out in
four months time uh it worked out we'll
do it again i really think that that's
the new precedent i think the two-year
hype cycle is a little too much and i
understand for marketing purposes i
guess it's ideal to have people talking
about your game for two years beforehand
um but look at games like to bring up my
favorite my favorite franchise ever
final fantasy 15. announced 10 years ago
right went through development hell i
think that that six months is the sweet
spot between and it's out now mic drop
and it's out in three years yeah so i
think yeah i have to wait and see
tomorrow what's your take on all this
you're like on the newswire yeah i mean
it's been rumored for a really long time
i would put money on it being announced
because you know we had a point where
bethesda said yeah we've made it it's
right yeah we've done this already like
it's just sitting there because they
obviously had this period where they
needed to figure out the new consoles
and they used skyrim to do it it was
released for the last year and you know
the team that were working on that
obviously fed that information back into
fallout and so i would be shocked if we
don't get a remastered version of skyrim
with all the kind of um dlc and like mod
activated from the outset because you
know they just launched we discussed
this on a lobby like they just launched
fallout mods right across consoles and
you know they have all their weird like
snap map stuff going on as well and
they've kind of figured out how to take
content from the pc where it was
traditionally locked off yeah and move
it over to to the consoles while also
kind of curating it um so i wouldn't be
surprised if it launches with all the
best mods that yeah you know macho man
thomas the tank engine one is the best
yeah that's pretty good
giant pikachus running around it's great
all your copyright infringement come to
a home console near you yeah um
hopefully we'll we'll see i mean so are
we all in agreement that this is gonna
be great because all this gonna blow up
in our faces but are we all in agreement
that they probably won't show off a new
like core elder scrolls game today just
to throw a wrench in the mix i'm just
saying yeah they're going to do that you
think so i don't yeah that's going to be
called card what's it called it'll be
called elder scrolls 6 uh
nightmare
nightmare all right
let's move on to games that they have
released recently uh that's the worst um
segwayer could have come up with um doom
hey that was way better than anyone that
would be right you were convinced was
going to be like a dumpster fire totally
because they were like they're not
sending copies out we were like well
that's the end of that one the beta was
also like the most i mean it wasn't even
made by them it was made by
it was a critical assembly
something like that yeah great it's not
great not creative sounding flash damage
isn't it no no it wasn't but still i get
i'm confused um quick but yeah they uh
yeah they the demo obviously the the
beta have not hotly received doom comes
out and like over the course of like a
couple of days everyone realizes oh wait
this game is like one of the best fps
games released in the past couple of
years um so they did sell a season pass
off of doom yeah
do we think this is multiplayer stuff or
do you think that they're going to show
off some single-player dlc i mean
yeah the the the discussion around
multiplayer is it's bad
no one cares it's not
it's fine but within the context of
other multiplayer experiences available
why would why in god's name would you
ever play doom instead of something else
you know and
it software has been kind of trying to
take ownership of it recently they were
in the news saying we're going to add
all the things that you want we're going
to start tightening it up and that seems
like on the one hand it could be a
preemptive move to
make few people feel better about
multiplayer dlc because if they just
announce multiplayer dlc for this hot
trash multiplayer mode yeah then people
are going to be like
why do we care but if they're like
actually we're going to fix this
multiplayer mode and also there's some
multiplayer you know dlc coming right
people be a little bit okay about it but
i don't even know what they do
i don't think the multiplayer is like
necessarily bad it's just it's just okay
it's just it's been done
unremarkable exactly there's nothing
about it and it kind of seems
superfluous within the package of the
game like the single player so good it
didn't this is a game that did not need
to have the multiplayer i don't think uh
although i'm sure there's a certain
population of the you know market out
there that wants to get voted out so
they feel better about the purchasing
decision um yeah mike did you play much
of doom yeah i just beat it last weekend
right so what did you what would you
like out of some dlc definitely single
player because you know you spend so
much time exploring that world the way
it's structurally set up it kind of
rewards your actual being curious not
just like this all out no holds barred
combat but uh multiplayer i've put about
an hour into like like you would say you
were saying it's not anything special
doesn't stand out to me i can play
overwatch if i want really great
well-tuned multiplayer i want something
that's going to bring me back to doom
for the reason i loved it in the first
place and that was definitely single
player for me yeah
folks who are watching live uh twitch.tv
forward slash gamespot or on gamespot
itself um i am in the chat so make sure
you get those questions in if you have
any thoughts yourself or any rumors or
any speculative guesses you'd like to us
to talk about uh let's talk about
fallout 4. so earlier today on the
fallout subreddit um somebody posted
that they'd gotten a like a little ping
on xbox
on the xbox one saying like a
contraptions workshop and i feel so bad
for this person because they basically
put up like the they use their like xbox
drm to like
put up the video of this thing popping
up and they've since had their like xbox
account like shut down oh wow yeah yeah
yeah even though this is like not
apparently not actually their fault of
responsibility that's rough yeah stop
petition everyone let's get it done
rolling yeah before the conference
and
that's a little extreme also yeah so who
knows maybe maybe he was doing some data
mining or he or she was doing something
like weird stuff we don't know but but
anyway the thing that pops up was
contraptions workshop so perhaps a new
type of fallout 4 dlc
same sort of question i guess like where
are we with fallout 4 dlc i mean it
seems from from like our perspective
like making videos about video games
that the cliff of fallout 4 has been
real steep like people are not as into
it as they were with like you know
certainly not skyrim and also probably
not fallout 3 or new vegas uh alexa what
do you think what would you like out of
new fallout 4 so what do you think they
need to go from here with us so i i
played the campaign in fallout 4 i
didn't fiddle around with any of the
workshop stuff i'm not really a builder
kind of person yeah um mods and stuff
didn't really interest me i really liked
far uh far harbor uh to an extent i
thought it had a lot of potential did a
lot of interesting stuff but a lot of um
the actual content of playing it was
felt like a little bit of padding like
you were treading old ground um
i think that if they're gonna release
more dlc it would have to be something
story driven because i mean that's the
reason that i come back to fallout 4 i
don't come back to build more stuff i
come back to experience that world and i
really think they did a great job with
the world building and the character
building like i love those characters i
want to spend more time with them so if
they're going to do dlc i think it
should be and i guess probably would be
narrative yeah i guess it's that whole
problem right where you're you're trying
to like curate the people who are like
engaged in your community but then to
like sort of drag back the folks like
like you and i who would prefer some
sort of like main line yeah just us in
the wasteland doing our thing doing all
that sort of stuff tomorrow what do you
think um i'd
i think it's probably going to be
something related to like you know
building your settlements and stuff like
that but at the same time they
recently they pushed the uh they said
they were
increasing their ambition or their plans
for the uh uh season pass content
basically right yeah the price is the
price yeah so they kind of owe it to
people having put the price up to show
them what that you know gets them paying
that extra price good point so they kind
of should be announcing something bigger
than just a contraptions dlc
i think they need it needs to be
something like a you know story driven
maybe a new region right something like
that i would like to see that especially
because you know they did just raise the
price on it so it's kind of like yeah 30
to 50 bucks i think
um diablox sx asking do you think they
will have any elder scrolls online dlc
announcement or just pretend it doesn't
exist i mean they were flying the
tamriel unlimited flag like pretty high
last year yeah so you know that was
obviously a big push they went free to
play they were trying to get more people
involved in that and get like get the
population up uh any of you folks fans
of tamriel unlimited i know kevin van
words back in the day had played a bunch
of it yeah same as the same as me not
really played it they're still releasing
dlc for it right yeah leads me to
believe that either they already had
that dlc in the pipeline and just kind
of churning through it or they've got
enough of a player base to you know make
it worth their while to release that dlc
i think the latest dlc was dark
brotherhood right which is a big deal
for you know elder scrolls fans yeah
that's one of the best questions i would
be i expect them to carry on for a
little while longer and see how much
they can get out of it i don't expect
him to like fully can it yeah there's so
much invested in it they've got like a
micro transaction system it's probably
doing okay for them yeah enough to you
know warranty keeping keeping it going
on yeah and it's on consoles as well
free to play stuff on consoles generally
it's in free to play yeah they just
opened a whole studio in montreal to do
mobile which i'm assuming will also be
free to play mobile stuff right let's
talk about that last year fallout
shelter was announced during the show we
all downloaded it and then the rest of
our toilet breaks for the rest of the
week were spent like with our batteries
dying and breathing yeah yeah what sure
i'm not gonna get into it so i mean that
was like a there were some great
articles after the fact where they were
talking about how like they didn't
expect it to do as well as it did yeah
and it actually made them quite a decent
amount of money and then they were like
okay well let's open a mobile studio
yeah i don't know if they can
extrapolate that experience into other
mobile games right that was very much i
filmed the product of a fallout hype
right it was the hype was so
overwhelming that they could have put
out like a fallout emoji keyboard and it
would have been the they did emoji they
did do a fallout emoji but i have a
follow for emoji keyboard on my thing
but like a fallout soundboard that just
makes like air horn noises
and it would be like the highest
trafficking thing ever at that point but
like if they came out with a brand new
mobile game like an original what ip
would it be like what other ip do they
have that would work on mobile let's
talk about skyrim for wake
yeah
mobile oh wow
let's get it done just quake live
running on your mobiles yeah let's not
do that yeah um uh mike what do you
think about did you play much fallout
shelter last year yeah like to moore
said for about the two days after the
press conference
he realized your battery was dying in
two hours and yeah but like you said the
they also like said hey the first
fallout 4 also it's ready in four months
i feel like i'm i don't i'm not like on
that side of development or you know
like how much does that actually help
them announce something and then right
afterwards they're saying it's coming
out like civ 6 earlier this year like
right she said we didn't know it was a
thing until like a month ago and now all
of a sudden it's coming out in october
is it titanfall 2. i mean
we kind of guessed there was a new
diapholi didn't see that until it was
almost
the same thing that would follow it
seems like a special case volley seems
like it's in that's like fallout and
half-life
are like in that same sort of level
right where like they're the amount of
hype and expectation that happens around
those games and of waiting yeah it's
like it so far exceeds anything else so
i can sort of see maybe fallout was like
a special case we're like okay we don't
need and they were also like very burned
by what happened with kotako reporting
on the script the boston the script
stuff the voice over stuff so like maybe
they just went like nope we don't want
the price involved in this for a year
and a half let's just do it on our own
terms um
yeah and you can say either way actually
because you know the clip's been pretty
high off the other side of it yeah um i
mean last year as well they announced a
bunch of hardware last year they
announced fallout 4 and i was
immediately on amazon ordering a 120
dollar pip boy edition do you think
we'll see anything along those lines for
whatever skyrim because
they probably got crap tons of that same
dragon climbing over that wall thing
that was that's awful yeah i know don't
buy it that's probably why you still
have crap tons of it yeah just include
that with it like there you go have this
alduin figure whatever yeah i figure i
think a wearable is way more compelling
werewolf a wearable or a wearable
speaking of werewolves no aware
wearable yeah like the like the it's not
really wearable
it's like it's like a wearable if you
want it to be it's a wearable if you
have enough duct tape it's wearable yeah
yeah and it's uncomfortable as hell it's
awful yeah it's like a workout it's like
having those little um
portable weights strapped to your arm
yeah apple store in winterfell you can
pick it up exactly
um all right let's move on we've got a
bunch more games to talk about okay
here's a game we actually know
some
a decent amount about dishonored two all
right uh okay a lot of smiling faces
let's let's start with alexa yeah you're
excited for this one i heard you
shrieked last year when this one got
announced oh yeah i tricked really loud
uh very excited for it i'm i've said
this before i'm really excited uh about
uh the story i
felt very i really i really felt like
the dishonored world was alive like i
was living in a world that existed yeah
and i'm excited for this year because uh
very well-known uh very accomplished
writer is writing the narrative design
carl ellison and she's oh yeah
imaginative person and has a lot of cool
ideas so i'm actually really excited to
see the direction this takes yeah i mean
we haven't really seen all that much of
it we've seen this trailer which is kind
of like a
i don't know what you got you know it's
it's it's previz or it's it's like this
is what we hope it will look like but it
doesn't look like gameplay
right you did yeah
and i think i discussed it as well in
the lobby like it feels like a very
smart extension of what they were
already doing like they're not
overextending you have a lot of
developers that feel like oh we're gonna
go from you know almost like batman
where they had this kind of like very
tight
game and then they went oh we're going
to open world now right although arkham
city was excellent like you get a lot of
developers that can't make that
transition as well but these guys are
keeping it very like smart they've got
two characters now um
contrary to what people believe you
can't just switch between them at any
point you pick a character at the
beginning and you play throughout and
the missions don't change depending on
that um they are the same missions you
just have a different suite of
supernatural powers to use right but i
like that they like to look locations
good and i think the most interesting
thing about it is they developed their
own engine
to to play play to build the game on the
void engine i think it was which meant
like they were able to do give that kind
of you know the the reactive sandbox
thing that they were going with a little
more life and allow it to do things that
they wanted to happen previously so like
one of the examples we got was like
enemies will communicate more to each
other like for example if you set up a
trap and one of them falls in it and you
know the one that's left over might tell
another wave of gods that you know watch
out is a weird trap here or something
yeah the ai was a little bit yeah so
it's that
like power upgrade and what it offers to
to the world around you that's really
quite interesting to me and and i'm i'm
a sucker for like weird superhero
assassin narratives and and it's kind of
interesting to me i want to see what the
outsider is up to now he's a cool
character and kind of he's he's kind of
like sitting back and just giving people
powers and seeing what they do with it
um because he believes everyone's awful
but is kind of like pleasantly surprised
when no one is it's it's weird how this
is like one of what must be one of the
most successful new ips in a while
because like the amount of i mean
certainly you know we usually do this by
sales but just the amount of fanfare and
anticipation for a new version of this
game i mean people have been crying out
for for years and years uh let's move on
to maybe an older franchise which again
recently i mean bethesda are two for two
for redoing id software first person
shooter franchises at wolfenstein
obviously that was developed out of
europe it wasn't it or bethesda
necessarily who were working on it and
one wonderful game um the the old blood
that came up what was it was the new
order and then the old blood was an
expansion back um do you think we'll see
any more wolfenstein is it a little bit
too worthy to return to bj baskowitz i
mean the voice actor actress for was it
anya right i said that she's you know
she said she she loved playing a game
where at the end of the game you could
shoot hitler yeah and she's involved in
the first one and is now working on the
second one right cat is out of the bag
if you believe her so yeah now's the
time to do it and obviously machine
games kind of were leading the kind of
the uh push for reinventing classic
first-person shooters and the other guys
who paved the way for doom to be what it
is and and be received the way it was so
i wouldn't be surprised if we saw
another one
more fans what about yourself mike yeah
same thing um i mean they have to be
pretty confident too looking at what
happened with doom and look at how that
was received obviously they were both
simultaneously in development it's not
like doom release and they said oh we
should do wolfenstein again right sequel
but uh you know they're pretty like
their track record for actually bringing
back these kind of these older structure
like structurally these older games but
also like
for modern palettes like doom itself is
a very old-school game but yeah it's
still something that you can people that
play games today can just jump into
wolfenstein the same thing it's like the
you know the weapon wheel you like what
10 weapons by the end of the game health
packs like the story i actually really
liked especially like certain narrative
choices you made i'm not as much of a
sucker for those like branching
narratives as a lot of people are but i
thought it was done really well in a new
order old blood same thing you could be
pretty methodical with it you can be
stealthy like i prefer to be stealthy i
like stealth games a lot but
the fact that doom came out and kind of
rekindled that and see where that goes
from here on out with its dlc uh
i wouldn't be surprised if orphan signed
two was a thing all right doom they did
wolfenstein they did let's talk about
the other great ip the one of the most
beloved first person shooters of all
time
countless tracks pray
i mean we're not talking about quake yet
supposedly um arcane austin austin yeah
but it might not be prey anymore it
might be something different which kind
of makes sense yeah so there was that
prey who was working on that old one
that got canned it was
oh i forgot the name now yeah so did the
video they showed off on e3 about three
or four years ago
um uh yeah it disappeared this was
playable in front of a bunch of people
as well and then
yeah there was word that arcane austin
was working on a new version of this
like you said that the name might have
been dropped i mean i cannot think of a
better
series to drop the name of like nobody
here's like i love i really like the
first prey
it's not like a genre defining
first-person shooter by any means what
they showed here looked literally
nothing like
the first game which was right you
playing as a native american on a
spaceship yeah going upside down and
stuff so i mean
this might be the first new new ip for
bethesda in a little while i think uh
dropping the prey name gives them a
really good opportunity to reboot it or
fix problems uh with it i guess the
franchise or whatever that they felt
they had with the first one um
and like arcane dishonored like they
make some really good stuff i can
definitely see them sort of
evolving it more if they if they're not
sticking to the okay this is a prey game
it's just a game game yeah so okay so
actually on to one of the best first
person shooters ever made in the same
guys as walton stein and doom
so i feel like nobody was mentioning the
q word until doom came out and then it
was like oh wait they didn't mess up
doom in fact they did an incredible
version of doom is now the time to let
somebody take another swipe at quake
uh it's been i think quake 4 came out in
i want to say like 2006 maybe or
something it's been a long while look at
this graphics quake 3 arena right here i
mean if you're gonna if you're doing 120
fov you get rid of the gun icon as well
i don't know what goddamn gameplay this
is monster gameplay uh so this is 1999's
quake 3 arena the other thing that was
talked about was with doom's multiplayer
being made in the sort of the
guys of halos multiplayer yeah then
maybe that was an intentional sort of
thing to be like hey you know what don't
worry our arena shooter is coming down
the pipeline uh tomorrow what do you
think are the is the like the chances of
a new quake i mean is this like massive
wishful thinking from the fps community
or do you actually think that they might
i think i think it's a little bit of
both but we do have some evidence to
support the fact that it might happen
like it's i mean domain names are hardly
the strongest
but like when they're so close to e3 and
they're being refreshed so like suddenly
a quake domain has appeared
right alongside a change to i think
dishonored and may maybe pray it kind of
it's it's kind of stacking it up against
you know maybe it will happen um like
you said it software have clearly
figured out how to reinvent their
classics um i know machine games was
mainly behind yeah but that you know
you've got to believe that they were
involved somehow um i think it could
happen i think it's got a good chance of
happening whether it happens at this e3
or the next one i'm not sure um i'd like
it to happen at this e3 but i wouldn't
be surprised if so a few years online at
the very least we'll see a new quake so
the executive producer i think it was is
that marty stratton is the the guy who
was in charge of uh doom the new one his
first project as actual in terms of like
production because i think he was a biz
dev guy before was on quake live so that
was the
free-to-play
browser-based version of quake
3 which is still available it kind of
had a pay model it didn't work out and
then it was free to play and it's gone
through a bunch of weird sort of changes
and sort of floundering in the same way
another tournament is so
if there was anyone to do it they
already have the team there who know how
to make
the arena shooter quake it's because the
thing about it is that like they've lost
so many of their the old id folks that
like almost it's almost like fresh in a
good way but also they have this
foundation of people who have like
developed the old ones as well uh
mahardi what would you what do you think
would you like to see a new quake do you
think it will happen this year uh yeah i
would definitely like to um and i hope
it does because like you said you have
these people they're new they're fresh
developers but they're still like
maintaining that philosophy that got
kind of passed down before them um and
if you look at 2016 and you think it's
not probably the best time ever to do
to bring quake back or bring something
back i mean we're kind of like in the i
keep saying we're like it's like a
shooter renaissance this year right
there's overwatch has
been doing like crazy numbers uh people
are like really well received you know
you have doom came back like we're
talking about you have titanfall 2
coming up which you know it's going to
more platforms hopefully that maintains
a longer multiplayer base in the first
game did you have battlefield 1 which is
going to world war one which is crazy i
don't think any of us really expected it
the only tournament alpha is relatively
healthy like there are people playing
that and there's still breakers law
breakers yeah totally which is actually
surprisingly fun yeah not in a negative
way i just wasn't paying too much
attention to it but you if if there is a
time to bring something back in the
shooter space that it's right now i
think this year and a lot of these games
are using kind of design and mechanics
that were you know born in
classic arena-based shooters like right
there's like you explored on the
overwatch series that you did yeah much
of that is overwatch it's just like mods
from yeah it's like action quake and
like i mean the grapple hook is straight
up quick to hook mod you know so
everything that works in just one spot
yeah yeah it's almost like there's this
new generation of people that didn't
play any of these games and then they're
realizing it's kind of right
they're seeing like this cyclical not
recharging health they're seeing like
weapon wheels and there's like what the
what the hell is this big kegs of health
and they're that's what we need yeah
it's like history repeating itself in a
really good way i think like 2016 is the
cusp of when all that stuff comes back
for like
modern appetites yeah wonderful stuff uh
let's talk about another sort of a
couple of little weird games that they
they were working on that maybe we
haven't heard about for a little while
uh i mean there was that year we had
battleborn
we had battlecry
overwatch was around there as well
they all sort of like disappeared i mean
paragon sort of came after the fact but
we had this sort of weird like third
person action moba shooter thing
happening
now you can see what they're all
different overwatch is like a client
it's like a like a class-based shooter
and you've got like your you know
paragon straight up moba and then
battleborn zone and something at
battlecry though in the midst of all
that i mean the art director from
half-life 2 a bunch of like really you
know well-respected developers working
on this game battle cry studios they
named the studio after the game uh just
sort of disappeared gone yeah um i
talked to them earlier this year and
they said that battlecry studios was
currently supporting and helping with
other projects but they wouldn't say
anything about battlecry specifically
right so i wonder if they they just very
quietly shoved that game like under the
rug and said like maybe next time
because like it didn't look good no
and from what i hear i never played it
but people that i know that played a
demo were just like it's
fine and there are other games doing
what it was trying to do better so maybe
it's just gone it's quietly gone it was
a game that was kind of chasing
uh
like a payment model as much as it was
trying to be a big new game right it
came out when free-to-play shooters were
kind of a big deal totally yeah and they
were failing left right and center a lot
of them and at the same time it launched
elder scrolls online around that time
which was one of the other you know
first person uh free to play shoot uh
games that it was kind of going for and
seeing that kind of
yeah it's weird but like that might have
put them off a bit and realized like if
they did the time window on
successfully launching a shooter either
with michael transactions or free to
play or whatever weird business model
that they were going for has passed and
and you can't get away with half-assing
it right totally i mean at the very
least free-to-play games you know
stepping away from the mobile stuff
which is sort of like pc for you to play
games there is like a certain quality
threshold that that game never really
seemed like it was reaching like like
you said it seemed fine but even like
the art style never really like
jumped out or it was doing nothing to it
was almost the worst offender in that
category of like homogeneous
mobile shooter things yeah it looked
like they were trying to make a moba to
say okay we have a moba now we're in the
space we can make some money off of this
now and it just didn't it never
never looked
just
never yeah it's gone i don't think we'll
miss it
i just did the irish goodbye and it's in
irish irish i didn't know about that
till i moved here yeah yeah yeah do it
all the time i see you just peace out
and don't say ghosting too go stay all
right
yeah yeah that sounds good that sounds
like i should try that no don't try no
no 29 years of experience don't don't do
it um yeah i was drinking since i was
one uh okay i i mean i think we've
burned through every oh no we haven't
sorry i forgot about this yeah look at
you
i know what you're gonna talk about
tickling your fingers together yes are
we going back to the well on evil within
so the evil within was also fine like
they're apart from the maker of resident
evil right right there were there were
parts of that game that were really
really good really really clever then
there were some parts that i think it
stumbled a lot over over its narrative
but i really liked the play and i liked
the gameplay the way it was set up um
tango gameworks is definitely working on
something they had a mass higher oh
really around i think before e3 last
year because i remember talking with you
about tango gameworks on the bethesda
pre-show last year really yes and um
so they're working on something and it's
a shinji mikami project okay and maybe
it's evil within two i know there was
that leak i think on like eurogamer that
talked about like dishonored two pray to
evil within two but um i definitely
think that that team is giving another
crack at it maybe not quite the evil
within right but maybe something in that
genre as well
that's interesting because then at that
stage you almost feel like they've been
like cul-de-sacked into doing another
evil within anything because you can't
do a second
like one of his games right like that
would be kind of weird it would be the
thing that i didn't like the most about
the evil within and i think something
that our industry has moved past
narratively is using mental illness and
unwellness is like a as a scary thing
um so maybe this could maybe they're
rebooting it maybe they're keeping the
same kind of like horror ideals and
doing it like a different setting a
different way but i really i mean
tsujimakami does good horror and yeah
super love a great mainstream horror
game i know mike is our horror games
expert here yeah
yeah he's hard yeah i agree expert at
getting frightened by obama statuettes
out of context that sounds really weird
it does
uh no like like you were saying the
combination of uh shinjuku kami and
tango gameworks uh and bethesda
potentially having something they
haven't announced or anything it seems
like
do you divorce yourself from the evil
within because i'm of the opinion
two-thirds of that game was fantastic
last third was awful okay and uh you
can't have
awful parts to your game if you want to
make a good game i don't know whatever
so the fact that they would either
divorce themselves from the evil within
name or start a new ip if i was to bet i
would put all my money on evil within
sequel right yeah i mean even if
even if it's not like called the evil
within two people are still going to say
oh that's the same it's a lot of the
same people like you said yeah there's a
mass higher but it's it would be so
weird like to not return to that
franchise with this same form i feel
like there was enough good will like
like even as somebody who didn't play
that game i was kind of half thinking
about playing it the heart was there
yeah yeah there's enough like it's not
like i
felt like everyone was talking about it
as this like awful dumpster fire or
anything it seemed like it was kind of
you know it was almost there but just
didn't really do it and i mean like how
many
first like new ips can we say that of
like loads of them like assassin's creed
watch dogs you know keep going they
spent a lot of money on marketing that
game i remember
everywhere you couldn't escape it and
they were very keen on pushing the
resident evil shinju mikami angle but
they probably wanted it to be the new
resin right yeah yeah but like the thing
that i'm interested in seeing is whether
because horror games are starting to
trend
into like the way they were classic
horror games like less action focused
like we've heard
konami's uh oh sorry capcom has hired
the guy who worked on metal gear 5 and
pt to create a more classic resident
evil game right and you know people in
this industry seem as they have a
tendency to have the same ideas at the
same time so maybe like we'll get
something that's a little more resident
evil um out of shinji makami because
obviously that was resident evil
four-ish maybe we'll get like if capcom
don't make the resident evil maybe we
should just do it right yeah and do it
like maybe we'll get a res
within that's a little closer to a
classic playstation one here or a
resident evil game which i'm totally
resident evil within they need to
capture that that uh the pinnacle of i
think horror games for me is the dogs
through the window
so they need to hit peak dogs through
the window that's the spiders that's
what they need nah that's the what are
the clicky dudes with the
the weird you know you go back in the
house and nah the friggin hunters
hunters
i never played the game i was like nope
i've completed resident evil i was like
nope 12 year old me was just like ah
nemesis man he was the worst yeah
absolutely awful behavior from him
awful behavior a man god somebody call
up his mother waiting for you down
alleyways
what are you doing dude
uh we are four minutes past the hour of
seven o'clock here on pacific time so
bethesda are taking their sweet sweet
time we are two for two on delayed press
conferences i like it it's not good e3
has been delayed yeah who knows maybe
there's more leaks happening uh okay so
let's go down the list let's talk about
what we think are sort of the dead set
like this is going to happen do you
think it is something like we've got
skyrim on here we've got additional
fallout 4s okay you want to do it one by
one okay okay okay for the three of you
you gotta do your roman ass the you know
sort of like
for both of these okay right hands out
skyrim remastered
okay three
uh doom dlc
doom single player dlc
you favorite you wavered this is if you
think not if you want
okay
do multiplayer dlc you think it's
happening so you want to put it down
because you want to say no it's like
snap map it's going to happen snap map
multiple snap map 2. uh just okay
okay fair enough uh wolfenstein too
yeah
so you work in the news team so you're
just like you're all about like leaks
guest part just in case it happens and
then people would be like that guy he
knows
cause if it goes the other way and no
one's gonna ever rewind
okay fair enough uh
pray to
or whatever it is yeah yeah or whatever
yeah phrase yeah asterix
whatever is gonna be announced yeah
sure i'll thumb up that one
a first person shooter starring somebody
called what was his name
bj no no no no no what was the prey
guy's name tommy hawk his name was tommy
hawk
i know right sure his name was tony hawk
he is the s is there's two there's tee
hawkeye related to tony
hawk tommy is surely his name is not
tommy i think native americans might
like be the winners on the racist ass
names of characters in video games yes
awful yeah maybe
shelter or another ios game follow
shelter two or ios games i think we'll
get a full shower update
they've been updating that game for 12
months tv though
here is more people for your vault oh my
god the cap of my vault please i
i had so many pregnant women walking
around they couldn't give birth oh
really they were just like there's no
room so i i like i made like two like
really highly this is how the evil
within two starts
high stat dudes and i started
just like roaming your vault
impregnating women all right and i had
just 20 women that couldn't give birth
because there was no more room in the
vault so i just had to i actually found
it actually send them out send them out
uh do we see battle cry this year no
goodbye forever remember that remember
that audience when battlecry pops up
um new expansion pack for for uh elder
scrolls online
i'm saying expansion pack not dlc
can you expand none okay all right
all right that's that's what we got
there okay so what's then what's on the
wish list so what is the one thing that
you would want expand on this a little
bit what was the one thing that you
would like elder scrolls six
necronomicon
he says you're forced to be involved in
necromancy
yeah from the off you start off with as
a vampire yeah who likes to eat people
yeah
okay that's it that's it that's just the
most sinister thing i can think of okay
if you're watching bethesda hell torment
look okay everything's more doomed we'll
come back to another one another name uh
alexa what about you what would you like
the skyrim with uh mod support because i
want those thomas the tank engine
dragons okay
realized in
beautiful
hd yes finally
i keep calling it skyrim hd and i was
like nah man it's pc game in it came out
ready hd uh tomorrow what about you what
would you like have you seen that
youtube series where there's a there's a
top five skyrim yeah a bear that
accidentally gets the the uh doverkin is
that his name yeah his helmet yeah yeah
the hell becomes dover beer no and he
becomes like the lead for his own skyrim
game oh really
okay i want that bear to be running
around shouting at dragons over there
literally anything else
i don't care about any other ip they
have give me a bear that can
do skyrim stuff you know what i want
down for it what do you want dan i want
i want new quake you want you quick i
want you
i want a big dirty man canoe quake big
dirty new yeah i want a new quake
dirtiest quake filthy like no campaign
oh no oh no you know i actually don't
know what i want because i either want
an arena shooter quake 3 like quake 3
style you know orb like an eyeball with
two legs running around
like just dumb
uh arena shooter or i want them to like
go back to the quake one well and make
that nine inch nails ass gothic
medieval nonsense campaign
that'd be fantastic or quick quick too
sorry quake 2 is like a military
futuristic shooter that's like you know
it's too common now but enemy
territories quake wars too
no
that was
that is actually almost seems like the
most likely one of those they would make
because team multiplayer games are so
popular that game almost came too early
in a weird sort of way yeah like
asymmetric multiplayer stuff
i do remember bringing splash damage
made brink
i think
that was flash damage that wasn't them
oh no you're right you're right splash
damage did make um enemy territory quake
wars you're right yeah that was their
first game because before that they were
like a mod team i think
maybe we'll get a sequel to that maybe
bring two
no who knows no dying lights already
come out and they've got nails
first-person shooter parkour
uh yeah so that'll be dirty quake i'm
all about that dirty quake hot quake
action is what we want have you come up
with any more elder scroll or i'll just
scroll quite a few yeah okay quite a few
go
chat as well by the way if you have any
ideas for what elder scrolls six the
subtitles should be please by all means
put them in the chat
uh ancient war secret
parts unknown
elder scrolls six it's
darkness elder scrolls six just dark
nice
light
shadows is that like a pokemon style
they sell two versions shadow sphere
shadow and light elder scrolls six no
that's just it's one big game set in the
shadow sphere do you say one of them was
parts unknown
secret parts unknown is what he said
that's an anthony bourdain
yeah
the culinary landscape of tamriel will
see conflict you're just going through
every
village that's a great model
yeah you're anthony bourdain as the
dovahkiin just eating all of skyrim's
cheese wheels there's probably already a
mod about like managing like restaurants
probably like they're the mod rabbit
hole is deep and dark
i wonder if they'll do anything related
you're right yeah so ea so interesting
ubisoft have a bunch of stuff ea
didn't although they look like they had
that x-wing yeah
briefly in the yeah
when like uh jade raymond came out
staged but this is the year where we are
sort of looking to see if some of these
especially like not at the hardware
stuff some of these like third-party
publishers start to dip their toe in it
i mean bethesda to me almost seems like
they're like the least likely candidate
i don't think they're interested one of
the most popular vr experiences is
skyrim right
but skyrim is like one of the most
experiences like blanks anything hey
guys we're launching playstation vr just
give us like a dining simulator in a
tavern and right skyrim whatever skyrim
dinners
do this skyrim dinners [ __ ] yeah you
just like have you know band playing
while you drink massive you know
but would you actually be having like
food like maybe it would come with like
a scratch and sniff book so you could
like scratch the food i had a good idea
you just ruined it no
it's a good idea this is how bad games
happen
one dude has a good idea then another
one comes along
i said dude elder scrolls six
and layer
that's like a game already isn't it
endless
bravery
that's why i know it it's stuck in my
head that's right
modern warfare get out of here elder
scrolls six skyrim again
we got some great ones in here uh
sweet rolls yep actually sure if there
was anything that's in skyrim
dinners uh argonia apparently is
actually the rumors that they might go
to argonia is that where the lizard
jerks live there's no place
jerks the
the argonians live in black marsh so oh
drastically misinformed you've got a lot
they've got next knowledge in your head
when battlefield 1 was announced we had
him in the lobby we realized he was a
scholar of the first world war
apparently he's also a scholar of
fiction tamriel yeah
very interesting one and tolkien because
the khajiit the cats are from elsewhere
but it's spelled differently skyr the
elder scrolls six skuma wars
or the drug like the uh yeah like the
meth labs yeah cats love it so it's just
so you're just in skyrim but it's a or
you're in an area and it's just a drug
war you're in a caravan right walter
white style and you have to like go out
into the desert and like brew your
skooma and then like set up distribution
channels and then benicio shows up
what was the benicio del toro what was
the movie recently
oh sicario zakaria was a good one right
i'm going to go back to the well of
names here we got elder scrolls
vida they never brought that out
actually that's a good point
that is living in dead city yeah was
that psp or was it vita i think it was
psp it was a psp game it was oblivion
they tried to like make it uh weird
not an open world yeah zones that you
teleported to and stuff like that and
recently the footage came out right this
is not good yeah some footage of it came
out pretty recently it's in the
graveyard of broken dreams along with
bioshock vita
oh god yeah
dreams
hey
i i put up my video once a year
for e3 i played some villa last night
separate is a good game elder gold's
fifa says sheep white all right let's do
this pretty good cheap wipe is a great
name elder scrolls sheep wipe we got a
lot of love for skyrim dinners here as
well
i'm saying bethesda scratching stuff
give me a call i'll give this for you
yeah black marsh is what they were
saying as well they're on skyrim dinners
um with the lunch uh the dark world thor
crossover
uh that sounds weird but about that i'm
okay with that uh we are yeah we're 15
minutes we're pushing 15 extra minutes
todd howard is shining his shoes right
now
uh joined us here on the gamespot stream
i hope he looks as buffed as andrew
wilson did today that beautifully
exfoliated skin the ea press conference
very very very fresh looking we do have
todd howard on this very stage on monday
as well ask him about time dinners
well obviously
after they announce it in about 15
minutes time um but yeah we don't
actually know what we have a month for
it just says bethesda so i mean here's
the thing though finances if it's todd
howard
trotting on to the stage he doesn't just
try on to talk about quake or some elder
scrolls online if he doesn't they only
bring him out when it's something to do
with the elder scrolls or fallout like
that's his remit that prey game maybe
it's not the first play game no the new
one okay it's been probably in
development for so long that they could
pull the
the fallout style we've announced that
it's out in three months
with that game
and it would like
talking dwelling too much on what prey
is or his history or that kind of thing
is bad well you're not gonna have to
worry about it for much longer because
apparently they're going live in about
seven seconds thank god so uh thank you
so much we will be back here after the
show so stick around here on twitch or
youtube or gamespot wherever the hell
you're hanging out bethesda's going live
we'll see you on the other side to talk
about all day announced enjoy the show
all
so
foreign
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
studio director of id software tim
willets
good evening and welcome to the bethesda
e3 showcase
yes quake is back
the game that defined competitive
multiplayer is back and better than ever
you know it's it's hard to believe that
20 years ago quake was first released
and
you know if you'll excuse the pun the
aftershocks can still be felt to this
day
quake set new standards for multiplayer
and push the boundaries for graphics and
gameplay
quake also became a pioneer for esports
and 20 years later quake is still played
in tournaments across the globe
the biggest of those tournaments is our
very own annual gathering quakecon which
will attract this august tens of
thousands of people to dallas
as a co-designer of the original game i
am extremely proud
and excited to be standing here today to
announce the next chapter of this great
game
quake champions
quake champions is a competitive
arena-style first-person shooter for the
pc
designed for players of all skill levels
whether you are new to quake or have
been fragging for the last 20 years
quake champions will give you the
challenge and rush you'd expect from id
software multiplayer games
now we know that high in performance is
critical with this type of game you know
so be assured as with any id software
game that quake champions will be fast
with amazing graphics running at 120
hertz with unlocked frame rates
yes
you're going to get heart stopping
action that will keep you on the edge of
your seat as you fight in classic arena
combat
quake champions also taps into another
hallmark of the franchise unique and
badass characters the game features a
diverse cast of warriors each with
different attributes and unique
abilities allowing you to fight the way
that you want
and you know that it has a long
tradition of supporting competitive
tournaments and that continues with
quake champions the game is designed for
world-class esports play at every level
from the world's greatest quake players
to anyone willing to test their skills
in the arena
so as part of the launch plan for quake
champions
bethesda will be supporting and
expanding competitive tournaments and
leagues beyond quake on and we'll have
more to share about that in the coming
months
i hope you enjoyed this sneak peek into
our newest game
join us at quakecon in august and we'll
have even more to talk about
and now please join me in welcoming
bethesda's global
vice president of pr and marketing pete
hines
thank you
thank you thank you tim
as tim said we'll have even more to show
on quake champions uh this august
at quakecon i mean it's it's right there
in the name how would we not have our
new quake game at coitcon make any sense
but right now we're not at quakecon
we're at e3 the biggest week in gaming
and this is the bethesda e3 showcase
so welcome
to everyone here with me and to the
millions of you watching online around
the world thank you for joining us we
planned the showcase just like we make
all of our games for you
now last year our showcase kicked off a
big year for bethesda one of the biggest
in our many years of making games
so let me mention just a few highlights
the older scrolls online was released on
console and became one of the
best-selling games of 2015 and was named
mmo of the year
we launched fallout shelter the very
first mobile game from bethesda game
studios and it became an instant hit and
winner of multiple mobile game of the
year awards
in november
fallout 4 was one of the biggest
launches in the industry
so you've heard of it good
and won numerous game of the year awards
including at dice and again at the bafta
awards and now fallout 4 is bringing
user mods to xbox one and soon to ps4 in
a way that's never been seen before
and just last month the new doom was
released
to rave reviews
now the original doom almost
single-handedly popularized first-person
shooter games and now you have a new
doom game faithful to its legacy with
some of the best graphics and gameplay
ever and millions of fans have been
enjoying the fast-paced action and
creating and sharing mods using snap map
the response to all of these games has
been amazing and your enthusiasm and
support for us has encouraged us to go
even bigger you just heard about our new
quake game let's see what else we have
planned for you guys
at last year's showcase
i told you about the elder scrolls
legends a free to play collectible card
game now as i said last year i am a huge
fan of of these games i play them
a lot
so this is a game i'm particularly
excited about legends provides a very
deep strategy experience through both
single and multiplayer modes beginning
with a campaign complete with a
compelling story interesting characters
and some great gameplay the story is
told from the perspective of a moth
priest named kellen i'll let him tell
you a little more as we take a look at
the campaign's opening cinematic
the elder scrolls show us what was
and what yet will be
and they have revealed much to me
spare us your stories old man unless
they can sharpen spears our warchief is
dying our enemies are messing for
another attack we must prepare for
battle we should go kellen
we have the scroll we came for and this
one smells blood in the wind patience
nog
i have words yet to speak here stories
can do surprising things spearmaiden
whether they are true or not
giving cyrodiil to the invaders
this is the story of a forgotten hero
who changed the very course of history
when legends begins you're set on a path
to discover the world of the elder
scrolls in a way you haven't seen before
the choices you make define your
approach and unlock all the depth the
game has to offer
a two-lane battlefield provides more
variety and strategic depth players make
decisions that change the cards they
want to improve or add to their decks
and we offer a full single-player
campaign as well as multiple ways to
play against the ai or other players in
both battle and arena modes
now we began public beta testing in
april and so far the feedback from the
people who have been playing has been
terrific to celebrate e3 this week we'll
be letting even more of you into the
beta to start playing now if you haven't
signed up yet just visit bethesda.net
create an account and sign up and be
sure to keep an eye on your email
also tonight we're very pleased to
announce that in addition to pc and ipad
legends will be coming to iphone mac and
android tablets and phones later this
year
as i said i'm very excited about legends
as it brings together an award-winning
franchise that i love and a new genre
and whether you're a veteran strategy
card fan or have never played a game
before it's a game we think you'll all
really enjoy
and now so long as we're on the topic of
legends let's take a look at what the
team at bethesda game studio has been
hard at work on
welcome here to bethesda game studios
it's amazing to think it has only been a
year since you first heard about fallout
4
at this very event and thanks to you it
became not just our most popular game
ever but one of the industries it has
simply blown us away and we're
incredibly blessed to have fans like you
seeing what you've created not just in
the main game with the add-ons and of
course mods it is just incredible
and we're not done yet we're excited to
show you what's coming next for fallout
4.
uh
so
and i can't get
of course we didn't just announce
fallout 4 last year we also announced
and released
fallout shelter which over 50 million of
you have downloaded and played we have a
really big update coming out take a look
we hope you're as excited as we are
about all of the stuff coming to fall
out we want to thank you again not just
for your support over the last year but
your support of our whole studio
really over the last 20 years
there is something else though that
you've been asking us about
and yes
we've been working on it
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
president and co-creative director of
arcane studios rafael colantonio
thank you
hi everyone i'm very excited to be here
tonight on behalf of arcane studios the
makers of dishonored
our passion is for a very specific kind
of game first person immersive games
our games blend narration and simulation
in a way that makes every player's
experience different
where players can improvise and where
choices have consequence
our games
encourage replay in order to try
different play styles so that players
are free to play their own way
in 2012 we released dishonored we were
thrilled that the game was so well
received by the gamers and the critics
all around the world
uh that was like one of the best feeling
for for us developers
after that launch my friend and
co-directive director harvey smith
took the lead on dishonored 2 so he went
to france in leon and worked with the
team over there
meanwhile i have been busy in austin
working on something else with the team
in austin
and tonight i have a surprise for you
i'm going to reveal
what that surprise is in a minute
uh
it's a new game built on the values that
are so dear to arcane it's another first
person immersive game set in a dangerous
universe only this time we've added a
psychological thrill
here is the world's first look at what
we've been up to
good morning morgan today is monday
march 15 2032.
you have a 9 a.m appointment with alex
in his office there is no duration set
for this meeting
there is a 3 p.m meeting in transtar
conference room a to green light
research and development plans
please confirm your attendance prior to
arrival
the most recent test results
good morning morgan today is monday
march 15th 2032.
you have a 9 a.m appointment with alex
in his office
good morning morgan today is monday
march 15th
good morning
looks like we have some tests to run
through today
ugh
good morning morgan
you're not going to like what i have to
say next
in prey
you awaken aboard talus swan a very
special space station
it is year 2032 you are the key subject
of an experiment meant to alter humanity
forever
but things have gone wrong of course
the space station has been overrun by an
alien threat and you are now being
hunted
as you dig into the dark secrets of
talus one and your own past you must
survive using all the tools at your
disposal on board of the station your
wits weapons and mind-bending abilities
prey will be will be available next year
on xbox one ps4 and pc we'll have more
to show at the quakecon so be sure to
join us there thank you
hi everyone i'm marty stratton executive
producer of doom at id software last
month we had the privilege of releasing
one of the most iconic titles in our
industry to fans around the world we
challenged ourselves to ensure doom
lived up to its incredible legacy and we
thank you our fans for making the doom
launch such a tremendous success
it's been amazing to watch and hear from
the millions of players enjoying the
many aspects of the game from those of
you gunning for the perfect run through
the campaign to others constantly
testing their skills in multiplayer you
continue to inspire our team
last year we told you we wanted to put
the power of creation in the hands of
every player through doom snap map
allowing for an endless stream of new
game play
and in the coming months we're excited
to be supporting doom snapmap with free
updates and even more ways to play we'll
be delivering new construction modules
including hell visual themes as well as
new props objects weapons and items
while creators can look forward to new
logic options and functionality like the
ability to create true single-player
experiences with features like the
popular weapon wheel found in the
campaign
and again throughout the year every
snapmap feature and update is free for
every player
for multiplayer next month we'll release
two new modes including a uniquely
doomed variant of one flag ctf called
exodus
as well as an all-new multi-zone capture
and hold mode called sector
later this summer we'll turn up the heat
with the release of three free-for-all
modes including classic deathmatch these
modes will be free to all players and
playable on any existing or future maps
also next month fans can look forward to
our first premium doom dlc pack unto the
evil the first dlc pack includes three
new multiplayer maps offering
cataclysm
and ritual
a new playable demon called the
harvester
a new gun equipment item armor sets
taunts and more
with just a month passed since our
launch we hope you've only scratched the
surface of fun we packed into the game
and we can't wait to give you even more
ways to compete create play and fight
like hell thank you
wow ton of great stuff there for
everyone that's enjoying doom and again
we thank you the fans for making it such
a hit
doom has received near universal acclaim
from critics and players alike for its
fast combat over the top demons and
amazing graphics everything that it is
known for
now it is also known as a longtime
supporter of shareware or for you
youngsters in the audience that's what
us old guys used to call a demo
and in a nod to that tradition we
decided to offer anyone that hasn't
checked out doom's amazing gameplay a
chance to do it
for free
so
starting tonight you can download and
play the first level of doom on steam
ps4 or xbox one
for free
now this offer is only good this week
but we want everyone to have a chance to
see why doom is one of the highest rated
shooters ever so if you love super
intense action or you just want to
experience state of the art gaming go
download doom and fight like hell on us
we think you'll see what everyone else
is talking about now let's shift from
demons of hell to daedric princes and
secret assassin cults please welcome
from cinemax online studios the elder
scrolls online game director matt fyror
matt
thanks everyone
good evening
this week is the one year anniversary of
the launch of the elder scrolls online
on xbox one and playstation 4.
because we were launching the game this
time last year i was a little busy and i
wasn't able to be here in person but i
made sure i was here this year to tell
everyone what's been happening with the
elder scrolls online
from the console launched last june to
the release of three critically
acclaimed dlc game packs during the year
all of us at cinemax online have been
really really busy
but before i go any further i want to
take a moment and thank all of our fans
for your support your enthusiasm and
your feedback we take it really
seriously and we continue to work to
improve the game and based on the
response you like the changes
elder scrolls online was named mmog m
best mmog of 2015 was one of the best
selling games of the year of any kind
and now supports a highly engaged
community of over seven million of you
who have been exploring this enormous
world of tamriel
let's take a look at some of the
highlights from the older scrolls online
from launch onward
oh
as you can see the auto scrolls online
community is having a lot of fun playing
the game
and our player community is still
growing
tonight i'm very happy to announce that
on june 23rd we'll be expanding
internationally by launching elder
scrolls online in japan we look forward
to welcoming these fellow adventurers to
the exciting world of tamriel
and for everyone who plays we have a lot
more great content on the way
for me one of my favorite moments in any
rpg ever was the dark brotherhood quest
in the elder scrolls for
oblivion it was packed full of
assassination and intrigue and like me
fans everywhere loved it
so i'm particularly excited for the
launch of the dark brotherhood dlc game
pack on xbox one and playstation 4 this
tuesday
in the dark brotherhood dlc you'll
travel to another location from oblivion
the gold coast of cyrodiil the dark
brotherhood has a appropriately dark
storyline full of intrigue and mystery
and brings all new repeatable quest
gameplay to eso
so please enjoy the worldwide debut of
the dark brotherhood dlc launch trailer
sweet mother sweet mother
send your child unto me
for the sins of the unworthy must be
baptized in blood and fear
this is the black sacrament initiate
a contract that calls
take your blade into the night
be rewarded for your service
in our business
of death
welcome initiate
to the dark brotherhood
and know this
in tamriel
no one is safe
especially from us
sweet mother sweet mother
sent your child unto me
our pc players are already having fun
sneaking around tamriel and learning
more about this mysterious group and we
can't wait to see what happens when our
council players get to experience a dark
brotherhood this week
but that's not all
a core philosophy in the older scrolls
online is to constantly make the game
better since launch we've regularly been
adding innovative features such as the
justice system and the champion system
and we're about to make another game
changer
tonight we're announcing one tamriel
marking another major evolution of
gameplay in the elder scrolls online
with one tamriel all characters will be
automatically leveled to content in the
world allowing them to freely group with
anyone they want and also to explore the
vast world of tamriel with no level
restrictions
this means
this means all content barriers are gone
and there are no restrictions on
alliances or questing from the moment
you get out of the tutorial
the entire game world is open for you to
explore freely you can go wherever you
want and play with whomever you want
this is the first time this has ever
been done in a multi-platform rpg we'll
think you'll love it
one tamriel will be coming to the elder
scrolls online this fall
in closing i want to thank the awesome
elder scrolls online community for your
support we never take it for granted we
work hard every day to make your elder
scrolls online experience the awesome
adventure you want and deserve
thanks everyone
thank you matt well done
now
we want you to get as much as possible
out of this year's showcase
so this year after we're done here in
the hangar we're just going to keep the
showcase going now for those of you
watching at home our pre-show hosts adam
sesser and morgan webb will be back to
take over the stream and they'll bring
you exclusive interviews and more
information about all the games that
we're talking about here tonight here in
los angeles we've built an interactive
space over on the other side of the lot
we have a chance to learn more about our
games play some of them and meet some of
our developers
over there there is also food drink and
to make sure it's a real party we have
arranged a special performance by
blink182 who will drop their new album
who will drop their new album california
in a couple of weeks and you get to hear
them live tonight as they start their
summer tour
now we have another tweet for you over
there as well a chance to experience the
latest in virtual reality from bethesda
weren't expecting that were you
now the first time anyone expo
experienced modern vr was at e3 2012 and
if you were there and lucky enough you
may remember getting to play doom 3 bfg
in our booth now at the time we had
solved some of the toughest technology
challenges posed by vr and people were
amazed since then we've quietly
continued our pioneering work in vr and
tonight
we want you to see and experience what
you feel when you put on a headset and
play the latest
aaa games in the industry now we have
two games for you to experience the
first is the just release doom
you can take a virtual tour of hell and
get a totally unique look at the very
latest in graphics
and true next-gen rendering from our
edtech 6 engine
in addition we think the greatest
promise of vr is its ability to immerse
players completely into virtual worlds
and that the best games for that
experience will be
first person open world rpgs
so we have fallout 4 for you to play as
well
wander the wasteland check out the
iconic red rocket try combat i'm telling
you with a pip boy on your arm a dog by
your side a gun in your hand it's pretty
incredible
tonight we're pleased to announce
that fallout 4 will be released in 2017
on the htc vive platform
and if you thought
survival mode was an intense way to
experience fallout you ain't seen
nothing yet
we want to give you a glimpse into where
we're headed with vr where you can
expect us to remain a leader offering
our games on the very best platforms you
choose so be sure to check it out now
for more on the second half of the
showcase let's check in with adam and
morgan to see what's happening and get
an update on what they have planned adam
morgan what do you have for us thanks
pete now we are here at be three plus
and this is sort of this experience that
you guys are going to get to see um
after the showcase we have some bethesda
vr over here now right now there's no
line so that's kind of tempting isn't it
so taking advantage of that and over
here elder scrolls legends for everyone
to play pete i fully expect to see you
at one of these tables showing off that
card mastery skill i know you possess
now in here we're actually adam and i
are actually going to be interviewing
some of the developers that you guys
just saw their games on stage so we're
gonna have a lot more information for
you so everybody on the stream needs to
stay tuned for that after the showcase
lots of good info but for the moment
let's go back to pete and even more
games
thank you adam morgan we will see you
guys in a few minutes but we are not
going anywhere just yet because there is
one more thing that we think you are
going to want to see
last year we announced that a sequel to
dishonored was in development marking a
new chapter to the game of the year from
arcane studios
we shared a few tidbits about the sequel
but for the most part you could say
we've been in stealth mode
until now sorry i couldn't help myself
dishonored 2 is going to be a very
special game one that lives up to
celebrated legacy and then goes way
beyond to tell you more please join me
in welcoming the creative director of
dishonored 2 harvey smith
wow
thanks pete hi everybody in dishonored
you play a supernatural assassin in a
steampunk city the game blends combat
stealth and mobility giving you many
different pathways and approaches
when the original dishonored was
released in 2012 you embraced the game
and made it your own you discovered
moves and combinations of powers that we
didn't even imagine we were thrilled by
your passion for dishonored and we were
humbled by the success of the game which
won more than 100 game of the year
awards
at last year's e3
we announced dishonored 2. so tonight
here with all of you for the first time
we're going to show you the game
welcome back to the empire of the isles
a rich victorian inspired fantasy world
with a distinct style and an exotic cast
of characters
for dishonored 2 we wanted to explore a
new location karnaka the jewel of the
south
our approach to world creation is very
layered our art and design teams work
together to create a strong sense of
place with a well-realized culture it's
based on the people living there the
work they do the architecture economy
the climate even the food and songs
in order to bring karnaka to life we've
created a custom game engine designed to
support our signature art direction and
level design
we wanted dishonored 2 to resemble a
painting in motion so we've given
considerable thought to our lighting and
the way it plays across every surface
we've created custom tools to support
the interruptable real-time narrative
scenes necessary for a stealth
simulation and the same is true for our
approach to audio both in terms of
atmospherics and stealth gameplay
all of these details make karnaka more
vivid thanks to our new technology which
we call the void engine
so
in crafting spaces for you to explore
we've got several creative goals we want
the environment to feel coherent and
complete plausible where do these
characters live and how do they get to
work is there a viable pathway that
makes sense where do they take their
breaks or stop for lunch
but it goes further than that for
dishonored 2 we felt compelled to ask
ourselves about the history of a given
street or shop what was there a decade
before the player arrives in karnaka
often you can see the layers of history
watermarks on the wall from past floods
peeling posters and advertisements from
years ago
we want every market every alley to tell
a story
and offer you the chance to see
something novel or intriguing
dishonored 2 starts and ends in dunwall
but most of the action takes place here
in karnaka
all right there you go your first look
at dishonored 2.
thank you
on behalf of all my teammates at arcane
and lyon who worked so hard to bring
this to you and my dear friend rafael
colantonio thank you so much for all the
passion you've given the game
in the first dishonored game you played
corvo itano falsely accused of killing
the empress the woman he loved and was
sworn to protect and you were blamed for
the abduction of their daughter emily
caldwen
after escaping on the night of his
execution corvo is gifted with
supernatural powers and dedicates
himself to avenging the death of the
empress and restoring young emily to the
throne
as we began to work on dishonored 2 a
single question haunted us what became
of emily caldwen how would her
experiences affect her and what kind of
ruler would she become
we envisioned emily grown up
25 years of age
and then we began to imagine what she'd
be like as a heroic figure
as someone fighting for her life against
the forces of deceit
we developed a vision for emily caldwen
that excited us and at e3 last year we
shared that vision with the world
dishonored 2 is set 15 years after the
first game emily caldwen rules the
empire watched over by her father corvo
itano
all hail her imperial majesty emily
caldwell
loyal subjects were going through a
difficult time but today we honor my
mother the late jessamine caldwen may
her memory survive through the ages
emily i look tired father
every year i think the anniversary of
jessamine's death will be easier but it
never is
i wish your mother was still the empress
i don't think i'm very good at this
you're still learning
don't worry about the rabble rousers and
we'll catch the crown killer eventually
people are saying it's you
hope these assassinations are a
misguided effort to protect me no
someone's trying to make us look guilty
by targeting your enemies
i wish i could just run away from all
this
sometimes you do
you think i don't know about your nights
out on the rooftops courage the ceremony
will be over soon
royal protector and father i should have
passed a law against that combination of
titles years ago
when an otherworldly usurper seizes the
throne the fate of the empire is left
hanging in the balance dishonored 2
offers you the choice of playing as
empress emily caldwin or the royal
protector corvo itano emily and corvo
are both fully voiced this time with
their own perspectives and emotional
responses to the events transpiring
around them
whether you choose to play whoever you
choose to play you've got to flee done
while you're home and travel to karnaka
in order to unravel the threads of a
conspiracy and take back what's yours
gotta get away
i should talk to the captain of that
ship
dishonored is known for unscripted
driven missions where no two players
ever have the same experience
there are many pathways to explore as
you penetrate well-defended locations
many numerous ways to find and eliminate
nefarious targets
in crafting the missions for dishonored
2 we've put a much greater emphasis on
big interesting themes either from a
gameplay or fictional standpoint making
each mission a wildly unique place to
explore
i'll explain a little bit more about
that today we're going to show you the
dust district an industrial ruin ravaged
by terrible storms that hit at random
intervals
in the dust district a militant
religious faction called the overseers
is at war with the howler gang the
leaders of both factions are trying to
take each other down you can side with
the overseers or the howlers or neither
there are many ways to complete the
mission
i'll wait here
and take you back to the dreadful whale
after you finish
everything you see here is rendered in
the void engine designed to create
atmospheric and exploration-rich spaces
to reach our target vice overseer byrne
we've got to get past a grand guard
checkpoint sealed off by a wall of light
a cruel security device reinstated by
the duke of sirconos
from the duke
we're losing too many people good
soldiers blinded by that hallucinogenic
powder the howlers used then stabbed to
death or dragged down by the abbey's
house
one young attendant got hit by an
overseer grenade and that was it he was
one of the duke's disney cousins or
something
[ __ ]
let's hope they do enough damage to each
other so the fight goes out of them
that won't happen until someone manages
to kill either
or vice versa
we've made much greater use of vertical
space for dishonored 2
encouraging players to explore the
rooftops above the streets
dust
the storm alters visibility for the ai
and for the player a random storm hits
and emily comments on it
many of the security devices in
dishonored 2 are powered by wind
a unique feature of karnaka so here
we're switching off the windmill to get
through the wall of light
there'll be a lot going on in this next
fight drop attack guards climbing and
vaulting combat choke and emily using
far reach to pull an explosive whale oil
tank toward her from a distance
thank you
all right let's jump forward closer to
our target vice overseer burn
the overseers are fighting the howler
gang for the hearts and minds of the
people of karnaka what happens here will
influence karnaka's future and the
endgames
we're going to use emily's mesmerized
power to lull a group of overseers into
a stupor evading combat altogether
mesmerized they won't notice emily or
even no remember that she was here
there you are i feel so empty right now
far reach can be upgraded not only to
pull objects from the distance but also
enemies so you can finish them off in
midair
this time all of emily's powers which
are new and all of corvo's can be fully
upgraded using entirely new skill trees
giving you the ability to customize more
deeply
if you're new to the dishonored series
it's all about options and exploration
playing at your own pace the game has
many different pathways through each
mission and also different approaches
stealth or combat lethal or non-lethal
and a wide range of wide array of
supernatural powers that will
dramatically change the experience as
you play
we're very close to vice overseer burns
office now
the sisters of the oracular order have
seen it
and i feel it in my bones
so this stalemate with the howlers must
be resolved vern is giving a briefing
using a projector we're going to plant a
stun mine and then link several of the
overseers with emily's domino power
so that whatever happens to one of them
will happen to all of them they share
the same fate
switching off the projector will attract
vice overseer burns attention and when
the mine affects one overseer it will
affect all of them
go check brother
right away
there are many creative ways to use
domino now we're going to show you
shadow walk another key power for emily
shadow walk is useful for stealth and
combat you saw it in the uh
announced trailer that we made for the
game and you can fully use it in the
game like all the powers that can be
upgraded in a variety of
ways with vice overseer burn out of the
picture the leader of the howlers will
owe emily a favor and that's just one
way to complete the dust district
mission
before closing today we want to
demonstrate another signature
environment from a mission called a
crack in the slab
it's another example of the missions in
dishonored 2 and how they're built
around big interesting themes
this mission takes place in a ruined
manner that's been sealed for several
years at the start the outsider appears
and explains that reality was warped
inside this place after an occult event
your supernatural powers won't work
inside the manor and even time behaves
strangely allowing you to travel back
and forth between the ruined present and
the past when the manner was lavish and
refined
here we're in the present when the manor
is in ruins
now we've moved backwards years into the
past when the manor was still inhabited
and guarded
looking through the lenses of the
outsider's timepiece you can see the
alternate timeline this is useful for
solving puzzles as you've seen but it
can also be used to avoid or take down
enemies
you can watch enemies in the alternate
timeline and then step through to
execute your plans
we hope you're gonna love the game as
much as we do
thank you thank you
i have to once again give a shout out to
my team in france they've worked so hard
and they are so passionate about the
game and the first game they're they're
really ready for you to get you guys to
get your hands on it and you don't have
to wait long
all of you can leave your mark on the
empire of the isles
because dishonored 2 will release on
playstation 4 the xbox one and pc
november 11 2016.
but before i go i've got one more thing
for you
this is the worldwide launch of the
dishonored 2 gameplay trailer you're
seeing it here first good night
walk on gold dust woman
wake up in the morning
see your sunrise
tell me
follow those
rulers make bad lovers
tell
do you me
shadow
very excited about dishonored too can i
please have another round of applause
for the very shy and took off harvey
smith
and everyone at arcane studios those
guys are fantastic they've been working
their butts off now one of the things
that dishonored fans have been asking
about a lot is whether or not we're
going to do a collector's edition so
tonight i'm happy to confirm that yes we
will be doing a limited number of
dishonored 2 collectors editions
the collector's edition comes with a
very cool replica of corvo's mask as
well as emily's ring and it'll be
available
through retailers around the globe but
supplies are limited and as we saw with
fallout 4 last year and you know who you
are they go out quickly so if you want
one i suggest that you pre-order one
before they all go away
also if you pre-order or digitally
pre-purchase any version of dishonored 2
for a limited time only you will get a
free copy of dishonored definitive
edition which includes the original
critically acclaimed game plus all of
the add-on content remastered for the
current generation of consoles
cool
now
games like dishonored 2 and all of the
games that we've shown here tonight
don't happen by accident there are
wonderfully talented dedicated people
working hard every day to build games
that thrill and inspire all of us and i
want to take a moment to recognize and
thank the entire bethesda team in all of
our studios so if you take a look you'll
see teams from all over the world who
are joining us now would you please
welcome me uh sorry would you please
join me in uh thanking them all for
their incredible and dedicated work
thank you very much that was great so
from quake champions to dishonored 2
from the elder scrolls legends to pray
plus all of the new content for doom the
elder scrolls online fallout 4 and
fallout shelter
and the latest in virtual reality gaming
it should be another big year for
bethesda now this has already been a
great night and we want to commemorate
this moment and
give you guys something special to
remember it by
so for all of you here in los angeles
when you leave tonight you'll get a
special t-shirt
commemorating this event and all of the
games that we've shown and for those of
you watching the stream at home adam and
morgan have t-shirts to give away so
keep watching for a chance to get yours
and that is everything we have to show
you from this stage so if you're here
with me in the hangar you can head over
to the other side of the lot if you're
watching online don't go anywhere adam
and morgan are about to take over the
second half of the stream for the rest
of our showcase from all of us at
bethesda thank you all so much for
playing our games and joining us that's
it for me have a great night adam and
morgan take it away
all right as has become tradition and at
these electronic triples bethesda came
out with a real barn burner uh let's get
right into it i think i had the q word
had just left my mouth on the pre-show
and then they just started the show
oh my god quake is back
quake is back quake all right looks
awesome quake champions that's what
they're calling us yeah uh for a like a
hot second i was really worried they
made a quake moba that that champion
words got like a bunch of weight on it
yeah uh but yeah what they showed off
what was i guess a you know just you
know pre-rendered cutscene situation uh
which showed off it was really weird
because they had like a bunch of
characters that looked like they like a
strong looking dude who looked like he
was at a quake two they had a sort of
futuristic version of what looked like
sarge who was like the main character in
quake three main skin uh but they didn't
really show off all that much it was
just kind of a bunch of
different you know what it looked like
was kind of like different characters
with unique abilities which is not what
quake was about but um who knows
tomorrow what did you think it is
i think it looks i thought it was really
interesting like they clearly it's
taking
what we expect from a classic quake type
game and trying to introduce more modern
conventions you know modern shooters are
all about
unique defined like class-based or
whatever yeah most class-based like
people have a they tend to shy away from
calling it class based now they instead
say like ability based or they build
characters with unique styles right kind
of let people just play to those classes
without using a boring buzzword like
class based and like what we're looking
at here is you can see what looks like a
lightning gun i mean that's straight up
a quake rocket launcher there's see that
green one kind of looks like a rail gun
shot even though it's maybe a bit on the
fat side um
yeah i'm like i am now just wanting to
go to quakecon because they said yo
we're making a new quake game we'll show
it off for quakecon because it's called
quake on and we haven't shown a quake
there for a while uh
yeah what what do you think mike yeah it
looks awesome i mean like just the
fast-paced gameplay like i mean doom
like kind of
you've been talking about doom a lot
lately and single player was great but
also doom's multiplayer leaves me
wanting more yeah and this seems like
this that could fill the gap like it
totally makes sense now yeah why they
didn't do an arena shooter in doom yeah
because they're like straight up doing
it here they're doing quick yeah i guess
uh yeah really interesting like
different abilities there there was sort
of like a weird blink mechanic one of
them had almost like i mean it's funny
right everything we talk about now is
overwatch
that's like the touchstone we have
framework right so like widowmaker's
like i you know
wall hacking basically there was a
character who had something like that
there i mean there was pop there was
pickups as well there was somebody
picking up something that looked a
little bit like quad damage so yeah i
think the interesting thing there was
like
they focus on they said two things that
kind of caught my attention one right
it's going to run out 120 hertz with
uncapped frame rates yeah which means
you can play to your eyes bleeding
whatever the other thing is said like
they they specifically name checked like
new people yes they did making it like
easy to get into yeah over complicating
that worried me a bit yeah which is kind
of like what does that mean i mean
in on the one hand
a first person shooter multiplayer
experience in the style of the classic
quake game simple enough for the for the
newcomer to take care of like way harder
to get in to a modern call of duty than
it is to like quake one or two exactly
totally yeah even three off within five
to ten minutes for sure but on the other
hand it could mean that they're trying
to really like simplify it in a way
that's you know different because they
are introducing
abilities and stuff like that yeah well
it looks like it anyway so i i just want
to watch this trade over and over again
and like break it down
figure out who's who and what's what
because there's so much little like that
guy looks a little bit like sarge to me
and we'll see this guy looks like a
strog i don't know we'll have to wait
and see uh yeah well i guess we'll find
out soon enough or quake on later this
year some more about it the final piece
about this uh tomorrow you said sabre
interactive were working on this yeah it
looks like saber interactive who uh
developed time shift and have since done
uh the halo anniversary edition yes
are working on this game in some
capacity alongside its software
um which i mean saber have done good
work in the past time shift
notwithstanding well halo master chief
collections online connectability
in terms of like creating you know
first-person shooter experiences they're
pretty good at putting that stuff
together as long as it's software can
you know fill in the cracks which they
tend to kind of leave around it should
be a good experience yeah by also means
because it is saber interactive with its
software it means battlecry studios rice
doesn't appear at all which is
nothing from battlecry studios at all
today who knows whether they exist
anymore yeah we had a we thought maybe
they could be contributing to another
project
and maybe they're doing that on other
stuff quietly but there was no mention
of battlecry studios at all
or about the game which means it might
yeah just been we'll have to see yeah we
it's got this real
deep quake lore that guy kind of looked
like anarchy who was the guy who goes
around on a hoverboard in quake 3. all
right you kind of look like anarchy a
bit maybe that's anarchy all right
and then that was like the
perfect pulled open right it was the
texting text and then it was just quake
boom boom trailer yeah i saw that rocket
launcher and i was like perfect [ __ ]
all right but does it do it again we
should talk about a different game
because otherwise i'm gonna i'm gonna
make a mess uh all right fallout 4 they
spent most of last year talking about
fallout 4. they spent a decent amount of
today's talking about both fallout 4 and
fallout shelter and in a weird way
they're kind of turning fallout 4 into
fallout shelter and turning fallout
shelter into 404. let's talk about the
fallout 4 stuff first of all you can now
build shelters
and run experiments yeah yeah sorry yeah
yeah vaults and and and also
put like so this is actually the first
thing they showed was the contraptions
workshop which was what we talked about
in the pre-show that was leaked and that
that poor xbox user had their account
deleted um or shut off so this is weird
because it's like something conveyor
belt some sort of rude goldberg machine
you were saying
that's what it looks like that's so
funny oh my god and then they went into
the next section which showed off you
straight up building balls
which is what you do in fallout shelter
yeah you build the vault and then you
fill it with people and you make them do
things and you can do you could
experiment on your
on your your vault can you make them
have like two rocks you know whoa i
almost had some down there uh two
stallions
male stallions like you had in your
fallout shelter impregnating all of the
females i got some listen i got some
real high stat babies after that
they were it was worth it it was totally
worth it maybe mod support for that
stuff would be interesting because you'd
essentially be colony building and fall
out shelter
in fallout but now they're adding they
added quests and right yeah so the
fallout shelter stuff then is that you
can now leave the vault uh to go on
quests you can uh
meet up with different vault dwellers
like bring them in but you actually find
them now yeah there's like buildings
what did you see was there like a
like a red rocket kind of thing yeah
they went into they like went into
another another building or another area
and kind of like moving around in it um
yeah no those two those two
games are converging they're starting to
morph into the same kind of i mean
that's fine they're gonna send yeah we
could do that before we can actually go
along with them was that a husky
new locations uh new combat stuff in it
as well pets new enemies rad scorpions
all up in your grill
oh yeah a new combat system there as
well i'm gonna add vats is that the is
that the pope
i don't know it's weird right now
and also coming to pc yeah it's real
weird maybe fallout 4 is coming to
mobile i don't know it's happening next
month as well so it's coming to vr
it is
right almost got it let's talk about so
close give me a hot second i'm freaking
out here my laptop's going to get
powered off
so
we were also talking about virtual
reality in you know how like ubisoft are
tackling and how yeah might be tackling
it we talked about it in the pre-show
wood bethesda different toe
dip their dough i mean they're straight
up like sounds like swan dies they're
like into the pool and they're flying
the flag of the htc vive it seems as
well yeah so what do they enhance alexa
fallout 4 vr yay and then um doom
right
if you want your eyes to bleed even
harder i mean the only way a doom
experience could get more metal at this
point is if you're actually like eyes
are bleeding and you're throwing up on
yourself as you play so it's the
definitive doom experience i like how
you play doom is like doom is a game
where you turn around very fast a lot so
i'm not really like it's great that
they've done it it's like probably going
to be impossible to play the game with
it but i like that a lot but what we
also saw was that uh
late next year they gave some sort of
date for it i think it was maybe march
of 2017 was it the htc vive fallout
thing yeah so they have they straight up
said the vibe so yeah i mean
it doesn't look like we should get peter
brown on here it doesn't look like
there's much in the way of exclusivity
when it comes to vr games most of them
are coming out on all of them but they
only said five yeah
which is i mean that's the type of thing
that makes you go to steam and buy a
vive yes yeah yeah i mean it could be
part of a partnership deal like time
exclusive thing like valve or whoever
saying you know
we'll we'll help you out initially with
promotion that kind of stuff and then it
comes to other places is it yeah i
wouldn't be surprised if it shows up in
multiple places yeah it could have
something to do with microsoft do
tomorrow because well actually no
they're they're down with the oculus
stuff aren't they yeah god yes so that
probably throws out any maybe maybe
that's why it's like the opposite of
that maybe they're saying hey you know
while microsoft might be showing off an
oculus partnership tomorrow don't expect
fallout to be in virtual reality on that
platform perhaps maybe
maybe i'm reading too much into it and
the oculus kind of ecosystem is despite
what they say quite close at the moment
they write their own app store and that
kind of stuff so if bethesda did want
their thing to go in
many places multiple devices like that
you'd want to start with five and go
from there yeah at the moment oculus
seems to be working through their you
know uh kind of sharing games drama
um with you know people figuring out how
to take oculus exclusives and moving it
around for sure saying that they they
want to be free with all their software
but locking it down within a certain
system so it's probably easier for
bethesda and they have that existing
partnership with valve and steam you
know and fallout 4 is running incredibly
like popular on steam yeah biggest games
on steam so it just makes sense for them
to go to vive plus they have that room
thing going on where you can get up and
walk around and yeah as long as you have
the room yeah mike what's your take on
all this stuff fallout 4 is like is one
of those games you get lost in just
playing on a normal screen right i can't
imagine like i wonder if they're paring
it down at all for vr i mean it's it's
obviously not gonna look as good but i
they didn't say it's gonna be missing
anything but there's a lot of like
character movement cues in that game
like when you get hit and like when your
stamina is down yeah are you gonna all
your melee stuff yeah so i wonder how
they're gonna like
merge all that i'm gonna barf
the textures could conceivably take a
bit of a hit to make everything a little
bit better like fallout looks like an
amazing game but it's a lot of greys and
not everything needs to be in depth
textures right there you know in a vr
simulation that kind of thing because
yeah you can easily gloss i mean pc so
it's scalable as well yeah exactly so i
mean i reckon
it might not require as much of a scale
back as we might imagine yeah it's gonna
be interesting it'll definitely sell a
lot of vibes yeah for sure i'm thinking
about it now and i don't know yeah yeah
yeah
that's all you need we just need enough
good games maybe we don't need that one
killer app you just need enough really
really good ones skyrim dinners skyrim
skyrim dinners didn't happen you almost
had it
you almost had it can we look that they
would do vr but not scary we could get
that ball rolling though we can get
people i mean he's gonna be the one you
didn't get yeah that's the one i didn't
get yeah the modding community i mean
it's pc what time is todd howard here i
don't know it's tuesday
stage with my proposal right yeah i'll
get it written down skyrim dinners yeah
just skyrim dinners
mods mods will make it happen all right
let's let's push on a little bit here uh
let's talk about
i guess the one sort of rumor that has
been appearing every single year we
finally had it confirmed uh the
i guess for a while there was like the
next gen version of skyrim or the hd
version of skyrim what they've actually
gone for is skyrim special edition this
is the playstation 4 an xbox one and
mods are coming as well it looks great
first of all right mike what did you
think of it yeah it looks awesome i mean
it looks good on pc right now yeah but
just the fact that you're tapping into
the console audience who i think i think
dave the other day in the lobby had said
i think more
morrowind deserves
a remaster a little more because that's
a overlooked game but this is still
people are still riding like there are
people that still play skyrim it's
enough in recent memory that people are
gonna be like oh that's perfect this is
the perfect time to jump back in uh
having mods is huge right um but also um
if it's a special edition it's gonna
have like mushrooms it's gonna have the
like all the dlcs um right okay
right now um which there's like four of
them
uh it looks
by this footage it looks awesome yeah
look at solitude there looks incredible
yeah water stuff looks like i never
realized that i wanted to replay skyrim
until i started looking yeah you can
hear that menu music right now can you
now i'm just flying i mean and the
witcher 3 like last expansion packs out
by the time you're done with that you
want to get your fantasy kicks on this
is going to be the perfect thing to come
around october 26th is when it's coming
out october is stacked
there's like so many games coming out
and then we're expected to play through
skyrim again battlefield
titanfall titanfall 2
this
many others something else i just know
it i can just see it i can sense my
google calendar it's just like crammed
full of games at the moment uh so that's
a very very exciting one and great that
they finally have it out as well it's
been the worst really badly kept rumor
for a while so like it's done okay
finally done
a little bit sad that we didn't see any
other elder scrolls stuff yeah we did we
saw the elder scrolls online
we did see a eso accompanied by
screaming stream lady yeah you're right
there was one lady in the front row who
had a little bit too much skooma because
she was very excited the whole segment
was the most long-winded way to say
hello i still exist
like do you remember the game there was
a surprising amount of people in there
probably still are there in the twitch
shot and the game spot shots saying i'm
only here
for like maybe they're trolling maybe
they won't because
yeah i thought about it for half a
second and actually yeah maybe no this
is the internet they also actually
showed off elder scrolls legends which i
mean
i never got to find out what happened to
the moth priest because the stream broke
yeah during their presentation they're
just writing the i feel like they're
writing the hearthstone gwent fad yeah
yeah which which the hearthstone's very
good gwen is a little more shallow but
it's still good
i don't know well yeah we'll have to see
it happen today if the rumors of uh of
city project red's uh standalone gwent
thing are to be believed i mean there's
a massive poster it kind of looks like
it might be it literally is a green card
so if it doesn't i'm gonna be like you
wasted some money that'd be like an
expert level
all right last but not least let's talk
about one of the i guess the more final
looking games we saw uh harvey smith
came on stage to show off dishonored 2.
they showed off what seemed like a
little bit and then actually just kept
going he showed a lot of gameplay yeah
tomorrow talk about what we saw in that
game so what we saw there was a mixture
of what i saw when i was at arcane yeah
along with a few new scenes so a lot of
the new stuff was surrounding corvo and
uh emily being uh the point where you
choose them so how it works is like
harvey said the game starts and ends in
karnaka and the whole thing is sorry in
dunwall right so in between it's kanaka
so the whole point of it is like as
emily you have ascended the throne and
now you've been usurped right push back
to karnaka where you've got to figure
out who's causing the kind of like
revolt against you then you go back and
reclaim the throne so the inciting
incident at the start is where you pick
who you want to play as and then we
basically got a showcase of the scenes
the different like areas of the game
which looks stunning yeah it looks
amazing that was the the void engine at
work like they've got some whole new
crazy lying stuff going on which looks
really nice and we've got like a
showcase of emily's powers corvo has
changed um based on what i saw carver
now voiced by stephen russell as well
the uh the voice of garrett thief which
like was such a wonderful way of them
saying yo this is where thief went
like we're the new thief yeah so corvo
has changed but a lot of it's like
subtle tweaks to his existing abilities
that make him a little more interesting
to play right whereas a lot of emily's
stuff is where all the new stuff is and
we've got to see stuff like shadow walk
which is a kind of stealth power that
you get around in a way that's a little
more sneaky but obviously enemies will
see a shadow moving around so it's more
like if you want to set up a strike
um there was one called mesmerize i
think it is where you call that obelisk
thing up here and it's basically like
you put that in the middle of an
environment and anyone that sees it is
like what the hell is this all about
it's like a tear into a different
dimension yeah and they just kind of
gather around it and i like entranced by
it and then we also got to see the
coolest power i forgot the name domino
yeah so it's like you basically you link
a bunch of people together to create
link everyone in the game yeah [ __ ] on
their heads and like anything that
happens to one of them happens to all of
them and they didn't show it here but
they explained they showed it to me in
my demo of it so like if you link one
person to a bunch of enemies and kill
that one they all die but what you can
do is emily can summon a doppelganger of
herself and then link that doppelganger
to her enemies and then she can just
like plunge a sword into her own what
friend friendly that is crazy and watch
everyone just how do they stop people
from like exploiting that i have no i
that's the point of dishonored right
they want people to figure out weird
ways to break the system okay and figure
it out
they just hope that the kind of
simulation is robust enough to
either not completely fall apart or to
accurately kind of respond to that in an
interesting i mean like
this is harvey smith it worked on deus
ex which is the poster child for
emerging gameplay so more added alexia
you were freaking the hell out when she
brought out her like time fad oh yeah
the time that was shadow walk right
where she was
the the other one this is some new
powder
it's now the time sure and she had the
time fan and no i just knowing that all
of those powers exist like emily feels
like she's really op totally but knowing
that those powers exist and i have all
of that at my disposal makes me really
excited to play the game because it
means the game is going to put
challenges in my way
that will force me to find creative ways
to use all those powers in tandem so
this is madness this is i'm just so
freaking cool just jump back in time and
then stab a dude and then jump back
again and then everything also looks
beautiful yeah it looks incredible yeah
it looks like wow the thing i'm really
looking forward to is if you go to
youtube now and type in like
um dishonored one speed runs or yeah
montages the stuff that people are doing
is just absolutely insane and like with
all these new powers the things that
people are going to come up with it's
going to be mind-blowing you know you
need a certain level of predictability
to to ai and that kind of stuff and just
watching the community figure all that
stuff out over the next couple years and
then finally get to the point where they
can like
just ballet their way the entire right
yeah this is going to be really
interesting to watch enough to launch
way too much longer to get to it
november 11th 2016 is when we will
finally get to get our hands on
dishonored too and it looks fantastic
we have one more game to talk about
one more game
we asked beforehand what rk and austin
were working on there was a bunch of
rumors um and then a guy came out
wearing a very interesting shirt alexa
oh my god we're talking about the shirt
it's such a good joke because this would
have gone over a lot of people's heads
went over my head you you saw it yeah so
back in 2013 uh kotaku leaked that uh
arcane austin was working on prey too or
whatever prey 2 was becoming
and um then i guess an internal memo was
sent around telling
uh people at the company in a very blunt
way to not talk to us and jason schreier
got a hold of the memo and of jason of
kotaku and published the memo in kotaku
and the memo literally said now that
they know what we're working on like
those press can i swear you can swear
those press sneak [ __ ] will be asked
we'll be sniffing around don't talk to
them
and roth came on stage wearing a shirt
that had a button with the word sneak on
it press sneak
that's totally brilliant and so funny
yeah like i was looking at a shirt i'm
like what does it mean what does it mean
what does it mean it means press sneak
[ __ ] so then you're like oh i guess we
know what's coming up next there's a
there's also a pretty good game after
that story yeah sorry yeah yeah so they
show what what we now learn is it's just
called prey they're just calling it prey
it is you know seems thematically
disconnected from the original prey
which is probably we sort of assumed
anyway and it's probably a good thing i
mean yeah maybe not because like there's
there was a space station at the very
least right uh what else did you guys
sort of pull from this messed up
groundhog's day yeah yeah
yeah he's got a nice apartment i'll say
that to him his eyeball needs a little
bit of work yeah it kind of reminded me
have you ever seen uh the television
show black mirror yes for sure
everything going on here after the the
rewind stop happening kind of reminds me
of something you'd see in like a black
mirror episode like something freaky and
kind of futuristic
like a supernatural
portal almost like we have some tests to
run today yeah and then it falls back in
on itself and the stuff that's happening
at the start is is you like
this is so open for interpretation like
you can't read anything from this it's
obviously not gameplay either so like
who knows like we may have a situation
where we they just did the prey two
thing again where this game might be
three years away
and by the time we might not see it
again for quite a while you know what i
mean didn't they say something about it
in terms of date or anything i was too
busy yeah they said next year yeah next
year they said next year yeah so this is
coming out next year the the thing that
that's really that's what they say i
think that's really interesting about it
is like they mentioned it's going to be
it's like a psychological thing right so
i feel like from what we see here it's
got a lot of influences from the modern
like psychological hurricanes like soma
and all the other all the big horror
games that have showed up on people
recently i mean if bethesda ended up
corning the market on on quake
on thief with dishonored and then
they're basically making a new system
shock with this with like a scary space
thing
like fair play they have just like
nailed 90 shooters to the wall and in
one swoop those guys are putting in work
man rice yeah that was a mate that was
an amazing conference it was great yeah
i feel satisfied same as last year i'm
like i'm like going back to my hotel
room like buzzing uh if you guys had to
pick your favorite thing from from the
bethesda conference uh first of all
michael mccarty esquire what would you
pick uh skyrim special edition
any excuse i can get to go back and play
that uh now it's gonna look great it's
gonna have mods
like i said i've been doing that on pc
for a while now but this is just an
excuse to go
play all these on ps4 now awesome our
xbox one alexa ray career dishonored
time fan
time fun uh
mr hussein we didn't get no skyrim
dinners but what was the second choice
unfortunately i'm gonna go pray pray
looks yeah there's something about it
that's also triggering like a dead space
thing oh god yes i'm like oh my god i
need a new dead space but if those ea
chumps aren't willing to do it
these guys will take care of me uh big
lot of love in the in the chat here for
prey uh some dishonored two as well but
it seems like people are pretty uh happy
about a happy about pray so there you go
yeah yeah uh
[ __ ] quake baby
is back
quake con i want to go to quake on can
we go can i get a quake on no
no no one said anything do i go to quake
on yeah let's do it go play quick three
the whole way though now quick two quick
one wait they're playing [ __ ] e3's
over baby quaker's already back i'm so
excited all right we are down two but we
have four more press conferences to go
ladies and gentlemen people of all
descriptions thank you so much for
watching gamespots streams all day today
on gamespot on twitch and on youtube uh
we have loved sharing today with you we
have so much more e3 left tomorrow at
our four press conferences we've got
ubisoft microsoft sony nintendo yeah
nintendo's on tuesday what's on tomorrow
there's something else on tomorrow
who knows the pc gaming show please
don't worry about that
it's not a real e3 thing that's it's
microsoft pc gaming show ubisoft sony
okay cool it's a lot of things to worry
about i like it and then after that
we've got three days of our demos right
here on the stage and of course our
co-op stage downstairs thank you so much
for watching thank you so much to the
team we put this together uh too many
names to mention you know who you are we
will see you guys first thing tomorrow
morning for all you folks in europe my
god get some sleep you've got work in
three hours time and for the rest of you
in the states get some sleep
start all over again tomorrow take care
see you then